good morning everybody uh once again
fashionably late uh before we get
started on our business today if I can
have somebody lead us in the pledge how
Kooker to the Republic for it stands one
nation under God indivisible liberty and
all
okay uh as a courtesy just to uh not
waste people's time uh it was my hope to
get everything done today but there's a
couple of bills that we still would like
to look at a little bit further so if
you are here for House Bill
1637 House Bill
1273 or house bill 11 158 I'll be
rescheduling those uh for our next
meeting it'll probably be next week but
we'll see how that goes sorry representa
right
all right so we'll get right into it I'm
going to open up the executive session
on House Bill
1063 relative to motor vehicle speed
limit within 10 miles per hour of the
speed limit and the chair recognizes
representative Gorski for a motion thank
you Mr chair I move to make a motion of
itl and HB
1063 uh motion is itl do I have a second
represent uh seconded by representative
Jones do you care to speak to your
motion I do thank you um 1063 I think uh
is kind of dangerous because when you
start talking about going within 10
miles an hour of the posted speed limit
my concern is that if we do approve this
bill uh that's a slippery slope because
now uh drivers might start to push it
even more and go 20 miles over over the
speed limit and I think that's a concern
so with that I cannot support that bill
so that's why I suggest I
thank you sir anybody else from the
committee representative
SES yeah I also would support an itl
motion um this is a bill that doesn't
make any practical sense from a
enforcement point of view it does not
make any sense from a public safety
point of view um it just doesn't make
sense and so I would urge my colleagues
to vote
itl anybody else representative
Jones thank you Mr chair and I agree
with the itl and uh just reading briefly
from the uh Department of Transportation
uh saying how would arbitrarily 10 miles
per hour essentially making any previous
engineering and traffic invest
investigations
Obsolete and they finish off saying uh
speed limits that thus introduced only
seres as a decreased respect for the
speed limits in
general thank you thank you anybody else
from the committee seeing none uh the
motion is inexpedient to legislate I'll
ask the clerk to call the role when
she's
ready Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes the clerk votes
yes representative Hill yes
representative D yes representative
Coker yes representative foot yes
representative C yes representative sers
yes representative Sykes yes yes
representative Rich yes representative
Sinclair yes representative Fox yes
representative Rambo yes representative
excuse me Vu yes representative Jones
yes representative Schultz yes and
representative clamon
yes one
two 19
Z
190 okay our recommendation of
inexpedient to legislate has adopted 190
I heard a motion for consent with no
objection consent it is I'm want to
close the executive
session uh next up um we're waiting on
an amendment for House Bill
1550 so I'm going to skip one we'll go
okay I'm going to open up the executive
session on House Bill
1403 relative to Temporary vehicle
emission control
equipment uh chair recognizes
representative stellers for a motion
thank you Mr chair a motion to uh OTP
1403 right the motion is off to pass
second I saw representative Jones first
um the bill is open for further
Amendment chairl recognize repres
representative sers again thank you Mr
chair I do have an amendment here it's
uh 2024
06128 I can pass it out to the folks
here and
um I think that's not that way there you
go and my fault I should have had that
done while while you pass it out it
makes one slight change and it's where
the actual Bill had 60 days I've raised
that to
okay actually a little bit out of line
out of sequence there but but next time
we'll get the amendment handed out first
so we'll let everybody have an
it I did mean to ask if I should do that
my
apologies
okay so we'll back up a moment now that
amendment representative s's motion for
the amendment I still need a second for
the amendment before we can bring it up
seconded by representative
Hill so did you get the second on the
amendment from representative Hill no
okay so now um representative sers you
care to speak to the amendment yes thank
you Mr chair so the amend like I said it
it's just changing the um where the we
had 60 days we changing and my offer is
to change that to 120 and my reasoning
for that is uh if you're if you're some
people work on their vehicles themselves
all right and you know if they Cur if
the vehicle is being inspected uh let's
say it's December or something like that
or even January and they go in for an
inspection towards the end of the month
and it fails they need time to work on
it so and it's no fun working outside in
January February March necessarily so I
thought one extra month would actually
be helpful and um the other thing is the
the the uh o
OBD2 itself uh sometimes take several
miles you have to after after it's fixed
and reset it needs to actually take
several miles to actually go back in
before you can get it reinspected again
so that's my
reasoning anybody else any other
Clair thank you I would take exception
of what you said because I think it
takes a lot more than several miles um
sometimes it's 50 60 70 miles depending
on the vehicle that's a lot and
um it it's it doesn't affect just
vehicles that you work on yourself many
times the garages will tell you it's
going to take time to get this part in
or etc etc down so I think it's a
reasonable Amendment thank
you anybody else from the committee
representative
SS yeah so um speaking just to the
amendment um it increases the time I
understand that my problem is that it's
yet a bigger change than the original
Bill itself and there are so many
unanswered questions that um I can't
support the amendment and would urge my
colleagues not to support the
Amendment anybody
else representative
Smith thank you Mr chair so uh the
statute talks about emissions but that's
not really what we're talking about an
example that I'm personally aware of is
somebody bought a Jeep Liberty they paid
like $2,500 for it and the check engine
light was not on because the person they
bought it from reset the light it was
about all the money they had for a
vehicle they drove the thing home and
about 50 Mi later the check engine light
comes on it was throwing a code for a
clutch which is really funny because it
was an
automatic I don't know what that has to
do with emissions but at any rate so
this person without a lot of money is
now potentially in a situation where the
transmission has to be removed to affect
the repair to pass emissions and that
repair is going to cost about what they
paid for the vehicle for somebody that's
low income and just getting by coming up
with another two grand I think 6 months
is optimistic but I'd like to at least
give them that long to be able to make
the
repair anybody else and I have to agree
for the years I've been involved in this
the one thing I do he is the emissions
and sometimes the difficulty it is for
them to even diagnose it once that's
done then you start looking at in a lot
of cases a lot of money uh again this is
not saying you don't have to fix it it
just gives you a little a bit more time
to save up the money so I'll be
supporting the amendment uh anybody else
from the
committee seeing none um I I did do a
Voice vote on our last Amendment but
then I get an email from our clerk
saying I'm not supposed to so we'll do a
Amendment
0612 all those in favor raise your
hand we got one two three four five six
14 okay the amendment is adopted
14 what's up the nose I'll raise your
hand for the nose please I was going to
official
two5 so the motion on the floor now is
ought to pass as amended any further
discussion on the
bill seeing
none representative Sykes
so on the motion of ought to pass as
amended
um I would urge my colleagues to vote
against that aut to pass motion because
there are what I believe to be
significant um concerns and unanswered
questions relative to how uh any changes
in the OBD program which will have
eventually have to get before the feds
for
approval um
and how that will all play out the big
the scariest part for me on this is that
if the
uh air quality people in the feds do
agree to the
change typically in order to meet the
greenhouse gas emissions standard that
they set for New Hampshire will have to
be met by some
other segment of the of the motoring
public I know this is a small
a very small change but um I just worry
about uh we are
already out of compliance with their
normal way of doing things and they've
given us uh a grace period by allowing
uh different slightly different
standards and I just I worry about
opening up that can of
worms anybody
else representative
Jones thank you uh um yes I did vote for
the amendment in uh because I thought it
was good in case this does pass but I am
opposed to the bill itself uh what
stands out for me is when Dees told us
that we could risk funding from the EPA
so I'll be voting against it YP fair
enough anybody else I'll just say this
um I will be supporting the bill as
amended uh I just don't think it's right
we're not we're not saying that these
vehicles are not going to be fixed it
just give
people some extra time uh I don't think
it's fair nor is it right for us to let
the Federal Environmental Protection
Agency Hold Us hostage from passing
policy in this state that actually can
help our citizens so I would encourage
anybody or everybody to vote for the
bill as amended uh seeing nobody else
from the floor I'll ask the clerk to
call the role when she's ready the
motion is out to pass as
amended Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes the clerk votes
yes representative Hill yes
representative D yes representative
Coker yes representative foot yes
representative C yes representative sers
yes representative Sykes no
representative Rich yes representative
Sinclair yes representative
Fox
no representative Romo no representative
a no
no representative Jones
you 13 13-
six 12 to seven I'm doing it one more
time one two three four five six n 12 to
done okay um recommendation about the
passes amended is adopted 127 this will
be on the regular calendar I'll close
the executive session on El Bill
minutes is it going to be um that's
consent
right
okay
yeah okay I'm going to open the
executive session on House Bill
1247 requiring relative to requiring the
display of certain information
concerning Selective Service
registration at driver licensing and
school military recruiting locations
shair recognizes representative sers for
a
motion thank you Mr chair a motion to
itl representative sers say motion
inexpedient the legislator there a
second um representative Jones I saw him
first uh do you care to speak to your
motion sir uh thank you Mr chair just
that some of the testimony we heard
especially from the major general and
the uh I think it was Lieutenant Colonel
that was here um they mentioned this was
kind of more one-sided and and U there
really wasn't a fair
representation of both sides so I just
feel that um even though the a lot of
the information may be true that was on
here all of was true I just don't think
it was necessary to put in the public
places thank you sir anybody else from
the
committee seeing none uh motion is in
expedient to legislate on House Bill
1247 I'll ask the clerk to call the role
ready Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative D
yes representative Coker yes
representative foot yes representative C
yes representative sers yes
representative Sykes yes representative
Rich yes representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Rambo yes representative auu yes
representative Jones yes representative
Schultz yes representative hundan yes
and chairman Walsh yes 19 to
zero okay our committee's recommendation
of inexpedient to legislate is adopted I
heard consent who was that
190 um I did get a motion for consent
without objection consent it is I'm
session
to
okay I'm going to open up the executive
session on House Bill
12441 1244 prohibiting smoking and eat
cigarettes and Motor Vehicles when a
passenger is under 16 years of age chair
recognizes representative Gorski for a
motion thank you Mr chair I move to
motion itl on
1244 motion is in expedient to legislate
is there
second who was that representative deaz
second by representative de do you care
to speak to your motion sir I do thank
you Mr chairman um when I read the bill
1244 and prohibiting smoking any
cigarettes in a vehicle one of the
things that really strikes me with this
this is a huge civil liberties issue for
me for us as a state to tell somebody to
say what you can and cannot do in your
vehicle I think really really crosses
the line and to me this is a slippery
slope what's next after three cigarettes
or cigarettes is it coffee is it
drinking soda so I think this is a
slippery slope I cannot support this
bill I encourage my co colleagues to itl
it as well thank you anybody else from
the
committee representative
a thank you Mr chairman um I just think
it's important for us to protect the
kids that can't speak up and against
their parents when they're smoking in
the car I grew up with a father who
smoked in the car against my protests he
trigger migraines for me and made my
life absolutely miserable and it didn't
matter if he cracked the window or or
what and we all know that secondhand
smoke is as dangerous
as this to the people around you as it
is to the smoker himself themselves um
so I can't support this build fair
enough anybody else from the committee
representative sers thank you Mr chair
so I go back I think it's on
representative gski was saying it's this
is private property this is like having
someone come into my house and saying
you can't smoke in your house someone
saying come into you this is my vehicle
and saying you can't smoke in my vehicle
or telling me I can't smoke I this do
it's it's just not right I
get adults should be smart enough and
want to be safe enough to protect their
children or anybody else that's riding
in with them to say okay I'm going to
hold off right but in some cases they
just can't and and they don't so but it
is private property and we should be
able to do it with what we want in our
own private
property representative
SES so
um I'm opposed to the motion and I would
like to point out several F SE SE
several Salient points um one as we've
heard and I would remind everybody that
in fact secondhand smoke is a proven and
provable Hazard to not only the people
who smoke but also to the children who
are riding in the car it is a confined
space where they often Studies have
shown that even if the windows are open
the smoke still migrates to the back
where children most likely are riding um
they're not always riding back there
admittedly um we have a history of
thinking in this committee
about points of view that
represent safety and the protection of
children
and that's really what this bill is
about it's not
about personal point of privilege to be
able to smoke in your car because you
want to it's about the protection of
children from a known Hazard it um it is
a secondary offense so that means that
the police officer uh certainly will not
stop you and and and get into your
personal private space as you will just
on that basis alone but would have
stopped you for some other offense that
you were
creating so if you're creating other
offenses that have brought to the
attention of the police officer it is to
my mind not a far leap for us to
continue that record of protection for
children for which this bill is
eminently uh suitable and
appropriate
anybody else from the committee
representative St Clair thank you Mr
chair sorry there we go at first I
uh sitting here was not going to support
this bill um I talked to a lot of people
my constituents listen to the students
that were here and also asked some
members of this group and other members
in the house uh what they would do if if
they had kids in the car would you allow
smoking if your children were in the
back seat or in the front seat would you
allow it and every person said no I
would not and I think that speaks to
what we're talking about here we know
that we know a lot more now about
smoking than we did when we were all
kids it's not a it's not a maybe it's a
fact and I think as representative Sy
said being a secondary Bill we don't
have to worry about people out there
binoculars watching to see if you're
smoking in your vehicle when it goes by
uh I think this is a reasonable Bill and
even if it just encourages people to to
not do this in their car where it's an
enclosed Thing versus a house um it it
can't hurt it's a good bill I
don't personally I don't think it'll get
through the house but I think this is a
good a
good example that we can set in this
committee by uh supporting us thank you
representative Gorski thank you Mr
chairman so let me try to understand
this the logic of the bill is to protect
the children from secondary smoke but
it's a secondary offense so if I stay
under the speed limit don't cause any
offense and smoke in the car because I
can now because it's only a secondary
offense I can still smoke so the purpose
of the bill is to protect the
children as a secondary offense but as
long as I follow the rules of the road I
can smoke to my heart content so so I'm
really supporting the children because
if I stay within the speed limit or I so
the rules of the road I'm still can
smoke to me it doesn't make any logic
sense of this bill that's why I cannot
support
it representative
sakes so I just want to be clear about
this issue of secondary offense a
secondary offense is just that it
doesn't make it legal for you to drive
in your car smoke
and it's okay for you to do that in
spite of the bill that's not what the
bill says the bill says exactly what it
says and to to think that you can
continue to drive in your car as long as
you behave yourself it's okay and it's
not against the law is is
logic I'm going to go to S somebody who
hasn't been heard from yet
representative
pondon thank you Mr chair I too have
wrestled with this I understand that it
is currently illegal in eight states and
it's a secondary
action where I'm wrestling the most with
is the unclear Parts uh of this
legislation there's a difference in
vehicle sizes between a two-seater and a
motor home at what size do we look at in
for cubic space that is detrimental to
the
children um right now we're looking at
it as a moving violation but nothing in
the legislation states that the
vehicle's moving I mean if it's the
vehicle's parked in a parking lot and
adults are smoking there's nothing in
here I mean from what I read on it an
officer going by could issue a $100
citation I just think this the
legislation is porous I would like to
see something cleaner I I understand the
health of the children but really it
comes down to common sense parenting I
think uh adults need to be adults on
issues and be responsible um so that's
where I sit on this uh and I thank you
Mr chair thank you I'm G to throw one
out there um that hasn't been brought up
yet surprisingly uh
enforceability uh not too many and it's
a legitimate concern most miners don't
carry IDs with them so at what point of
delaying a traffic stop um is is needs
to be there to prove how old some of
these children in question might be I
find it as a as a problem did you still
have your hand up representative sellers
thank you Mr chair the the other two
points I want to bring up is
that in my case my wife and I bore these
children we rais these children they're
our children they're not the state's
children so they're ours to take care of
and hopefully we will do the best we can
but that's that's one point and and I
don't want the state infringing on my
rights on my kids for sure or my
property for that matter if I don't have
to the second thing is it it talks about
ecigarettes now I haven't seen any study
and I don't know but that's vaping and
vaping is I thought it's just vapor and
I didn't know if that's cancerous or not
or whatnot so because we did talk about
cancer here I think so I you're
inclusing of everything and I'm just
concerned about
that
okay anything new on this
debate so I I'll give you I'll give you
Clair representative stclair thank you
Mr chair I just wanted to respond and
and if only we knew that all parents are
okay anything to do representative
Jones Thank you Mr chair and I will be
different um there's there's a big
difference between uh rights and
Privileges and operating a vehicle in
New Hampshire is a privilege it's not a
right and it's our it's basically our
duty to make that privilege as safe as
it is for the same reason uh you can't
have open containers for the same reason
you can't um
use a cell phone and and so on uh I
think anything we can safely control
within the bounds of operating a vehicle
is our duty to do it thank
you okay was seeing nobody else on U
that wishes to
speak I
will as I'm losing my train of thought
here um the motion on the floor is
inexpedient to legis lat on House Bill
1244 I'll ask the clerk to call the role
when she's
ready Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
de yes representative Coker yes
representative foot yes representative C
yes representative sers yes
representative Sykes no representative
rich representative Sinclair no
representative
Fox no representative Rambo no
representative Ao No representative
Jones
no representative Schultz no
representative FL PL mundon
yes 11
to8
yes okay our committee's recommendation
of in expedient to legislate is adopted
118 obviously regular calendar I'm going
to close the executive session on this
one next up we will get
1467 um yeah actually the two of them we
have uh 1244 or even 1403 um are there
reports okay just before we leave before
we leave today I do want to I need to
get all these reports today too whether
against
I'm going to open up the executive
session on House Bill 1467 FN relative
to child passenger protection chair
recognizes representative Coker for a
motion uh thank you chairman I make
motion of itl on
1467 motion is inexpedient the legislate
is there a
second second representative uh seconded
by representative Gorski do you care to
speak to your motion yes Mr chair you
know I I think that the Bill's got good
intentions but it's just too broad um
I've got a family friend who's got a
12-year-old who sits in the front seat
of my car sometimes and I mean he's he's
close to Six Feet my my daughter's 12
and she's you know she's sits in the
front she fits it it's it's just not um
it's just too broad
so fair enough anybody else from the
committee seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the role when she's ready the
motion is in expedient to
legislate Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative
Smith yes clerk votes yes representative
Hill yes representative J representative
Coker yes representative FL yes
representative C yes representative sers
yes representative Sykes yes
representative BR yes representative
Sinclair yes representative
Fox yes representative Rambo yes
representative VI yes representative
Jones yes representative Schultz yes
representative pund
yes chairman Walsh yes 19 to zero our
recommendation is adopted 19 to zero um
I Heard a motion for consent without
objection consent that is I'll close the
executive session on House Bill
also
good I'll open up the executive session
on House Bill
1457 establishing penalties for driving
over
covered wooden bridges and vehicles that
exceed posted limits and for vehicular
damage to covering wooden bridges chair
recognizes representative foot for
motion
thank you Mr chair I move to ought to
1457 motion is ought to pass uh seconded
by representative London do you care to
speak to your motion yes thank you Mr
chair so this bill um quite honestly
it's a simple um simple legislation that
makes a lot of sense um basically it's a
it's a preventative deterrent to um
maintain the Integrity of these wooden
bridges that
in most cases are historical in nature
um and repeated damaging to these
Bridges can become um a safety issue uh
we heard testimony that there was school
buses driving over it you know um you
know God forbid that would have happened
and and something tragic happened with
with a bus load of children or a bus
load of just people in general um so
essentially this bill would raise the
fine from $62 to $11,000 and up to um
$2,000 as needed and basically it's a
deterrent
to um minimize oversized Vehicles
driving
around uh driving through the bridge and
actually take a separate route so I I
think it's uh it's Common Sense
legislation I think we should pass
it thank you sir anybody else from the
committee representative syes yeah I
also would support the OTP um there are
lots of communities that have uh
historical wooden bridges this is not a
is ol ated incident in any particular
area of the state um PE they they help
with tourism uh they help with I mean
there's literally something called The
Covered Bridge uh Road Rally where you
know Road rers go through covered
bridges that's great but if you damage
the bridge and it has to be closed it's
really it that's a really unfortunate
thing and plus people may be injured and
so for the that all the reasons
elucidated by representative foot I
think we should vote uh on to
pass thank you anybody else
representative
Jones Thank you Mr chair um yeah covered
bridges are part of the culture of New
Hampshire and I think we deserve to
protect them and uh I I don't think $62
is a deterrent I think we do need to uh
increase that and there's also a
companion bill I I believe it's in
criminal justice allowing uh cameras on
these Bridges so we can uh catch those
who were uh violating so I think this is
a good bill to pass and I would like to
see it
happen representative plon yeah just to
add to uh comments of my constitues here
the bill besides adding a fine up
thousand or up to 200000 it also uh
specifies that any
damage uh would be uh responsible for
replacement repair of the bridge uh if
any vehicle in violation so it's beyond
f L it's also they're going to pay the
damage fair enough anybody else from the
committee represent
Smith yeah uh I have a question so the
bill is peppered with car vs from RSA
A
39a
a 23439 does not have a subsection I
think this might be a typo and perhaps
23441 which is under the transportation
statutes not motor vehicle Bridge
regulations
23441 is the generic penalty section for
all of
234 any person who operates or attempts
to operate any vehicle on such bridge
when the weight of the load inclusive of
the vehicle exceeds such posted load
limit without such permitter who
operates or attempts to operate any
vehicle on such bridge in violation of
such conditions what a word salad but
anyway um shall not be found more than
$100 the bill I don't think works unless
throughout I'll hold that time for a
second anything else from anybody else
committee
just to keep it the discussion open um I
can't recess it with a Time specific uh
and if we were going to try to fix it
recess it okay recess it I'm good with
that um with a Time specific um I could
do that I don't know if I need to do
that if I'm going to push it up till
next week we will reschedule it for sure
but just to keep it on the up and up I'm
going to recess it um next week is that
the vacation
20th that's okay we'll take care of it
next week so I'll cover all my bases
here due to the technical change that we
just discovered I will recess the
executive session on House Bill
20th so I'll close it for now I didn't
close it iess you don't you don't have
to hold on you don't have to turn in
committee then we go from that point
forward
yep and next up we'll get into to House
Bill
1416 back anyway yeah we have to come
back next week anyways
yeah which I means I got to put it in my
calendar now before the space
disappears
yes she
Amendment
okay I'm going to open up the executive
session on House Bill 1416 FN relative
to prohibiting parking of non-electric
vehicles in spaces designated for
charging electric
Jones Thank you Mr chairman I would move
to aop pass the motion is ought to pass
is there a
second St Clair second seconded by
representative St Clair car to speak to
your motion sir thank you Mr chairman uh
this is just a common sense Bill we we
put that thousand of dollars or private
companies put thousands of dollars into
creating these spaces and for soone it
just inconsiderate for someone to be
taking these spaces but I guess it's
bill anybody else from the
committee representa CER thank you Mr
chairman so I don't think we should be
legislating common courtesy um as
there's more electric spaces that come
available I think they're going to be
more and more of a higher percentage of
the parking lot totals so uh this might
be a temporary issue that's going to
solve itself as the electric vehicle
technology kind of U becomes more common
in our uh in our
state anybody else
representative thank you Mr chairman I
see this more as
uh kind of a you're preventing somebody
from earning their income by blocking
these spaces it's the equivalent of
putting a car in a in place of a gas
pump and then going in the store
shopping you you're preventing anybody
from using the gas pump and you're
preventing the the business from earning
Revenue so to me this is kind of
equivalent to theft by blocking these
spaces you're block you're preventing
somebody from earning their income um it
maybe just a piece of their income and
maybe their entire income uh somebody
has a bank of of uh charging stations
and that's where they earn their money
so just like somebody can have a gas
station that doesn't have any other
business involved you're you're stealing
from them and you preventing them from
from earning their income and this is
you know this is just a business bill as
far as I'm
concerned anybody else from the
committee representative Gorski thank
you Mr chairman um when I heard the
testimony of this bill and read it in my
experience driving around outside of
being a state rep in my business I drive
around see my clients and pretty much
most of the New England states at some
point in time I've never ever ever seen
this kind of situation happened now it
may be just luck in those times when I
was driving around and kind of looking
but I've never seen it happen and
according to testimony it seems to be
happening a lot kind of in the Keen area
but I've personally not seen it so with
that I I just as uh representative Coker
says it's legislating common sense I
just can't support
it anybody
else well without extending the debate
on this the motion
is ought to pass on House Bill 1416 I'll
ready shall I the motion is off to pass
was vice chairman Gorski
no representative Smith no clerk votes
no representative Hill no representative
D no representative Coker no
representative foot no representative C
no representative sellers no
representative
Sykes yes representative Rich
representative Sinclair yes
representative
Fox yes representative Romo yes
represent Veo yes representative Jones
yes representative Schultz yes
representative pund yes and chairman
Walsh
no nine to 10 fails fails so the motion
about to pass on House Bill 1416 fails
is there another motion representative
sellers a motion to uh itl HB 1416 okay
a motion of in expedient the legislator
been oper is there a
second representative Hill um any any
further debate or should we just get to
it just one question uh Mr chair is that
is uh again in this bill I think I I
could take a picture of a vehicle
sitting in uh in a space there that's
occupied an electric space it could even
be an electric vehicle that's not
plugged in I could take that picture
bring down the police and they could
ticket representative
SES yeah so um I I would be voting
against the OTP and um I excuse me itl
get get show my age here sorry folks um
I vote against the itl
because we often talk about
how we shouldn't it shouldn't be
necessary to vote to legislate for
common sense and yet we do it every day
we every day we have bills that come
before us that that the argument is made
well it's just a simple Bill and it
makes Common Sense well what changed why
would we then not is that the only
argument against this bill secondarily
uh beside the argument of which was I
think incredibly important about uh it's
an income issue for folks it's it's also
a safety issue from the point of view
that if you have a electric vehicle and
you are Char you are driving down the
road on vacation visiting our wonderful
State and you know that you have the
range to get to a certain place and then
you get there and it's late at night and
somebody is parked in your space and you
are stuck there with your children
because you can't get into that space I
think that's really something that we
should take
be mindful of I also think that
um not withstanding the fact that maybe
I you you or I or somebody else hasn't
seen this happen that does not mean that
it is not happening and in fact we had
testimony that indicates that it is
happening and I just I just think that
this is
uh a way to uh discourage the use of
electric vehicles which I I think is
unfortunate I think we should be
encouraging the use of electric vehicles
for a lot of different reasons I know
that's a uh a loaded topic but this is a
a change that affects businesses it is a
change that will help businesses this is
a change that will help people in their
Public Safety when they're traveling so
that they can prepare and be and feel
comfortable that when they get to the
spot where that might be only one single
charging station that that it will be
available for them we want to encourage
people to feel comfortable about
charging as more and more electric
vehicles come on the road we need to
make sure that they people feel that
they can come to New Hampshire which is
already
a I might even call it a black hole of
electric vehicle charging stations
relative to per capita vers versus other
New England states when are we going to
wake up and say wow we don't want to do
that we're throwing away what is now I
think I don't want to quote percentages
but a more a significant proportion of
the traveling public and is only going
to get
greater representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman um I was hesitating to actually
speak on this
but um the representatives comments
about uh the a scenario with the family
uh running down the street and not
having a place to uh to pull their car
in to plug in um I've been in that
situation in in a car um late at night
and found no gas stations open um by
your logic it would mean that every gas
station should should be open and
available to me when I need it um and it
doesn't happen that way at least here um
I guess my assumption would be that the
person has parked in that spot for less
time than what a gas station is closed
um so at least there would be some way
of at some point getting there I've not
found any place that only has one
electric charging station at a location
I the ones that I see usually well the
one that's nearby me has six I don't
know if there's there are places that
only have one but the real problem I
have with this is what representative
sellers Mo um mentioned earlier um to my
knowledge the
only opportunity that we
have um for an ordinary citizen to take
a photo of a of a car and have an actual
ticket issued is with handicap plates um
I'm not sure if that's true but I think
that's true um I think this
is I don't think this Rises to the level
of the handicap plate um and for that
I representative
London thank you uh Mr
chair I can't support the U the current
motion to itl um I being a
representative from Nashville um I can
say I've seen at least twice uh gasoline
vehicles parked
typically at stores or restaurants in uh
where electric electric vehicle spots um
it's usually uh that these these
particular parking spots are close to
the building thus running electric lines
and because it's close to the building
close to the door people tend to take
these SPS uh instead of an electric
vehicle thereby hampering those with
electric vehicles for a parking spot uh
it's beyond courtesy
it's just uh I think
it's it's it's a need to legislate this
regarding taking a picture uh larger
municipalities the police department
don't even do the parking tickets it
goes to parking enforcement so typically
an individual would call the police
department they in turn would radio
someone and parking enforcement it could
be 45 minutes to an hour or more for a
parking enforcement Personnel to get to
that spot to witness uh a violation and
ticket um so I just don't see that
happening
um and I question whether or not it is
illegal where they could even issue a
ticket uh because it's a registered
vehicle I think the only caveat to
parking in these spots would be a
handicap plate where they can they can
park in any legal parking spot and for
that I I have no issue with someone
handicapped parking as close to the door
uh because of their conditions but I
just can't support itl on this I I don't
think it's bad legislation thank you Mr
chair okay represent rumo thank you Mr
chair I I have to say I'm really
surprised by the tenor of some these
comments given how often we talk about
the importance of private property
rights and and people being able to
carry out their businesses um we heard
bipartisan testimony that this is huge
investment putting in these spaces and
charging stations uh that it is
preventing business owners from
recouping their Investments their
expenses um impacting their incomes um
and I agree it' be nice if people were
courteous and didn't take the spot but
essentially we're saying it's oh if
we are agreeing with the itl that it's
okay for someone to consciously block a
spot for whatever their reason may be
that's preventing someone from earning
their income on that spot and I just I
I'm really surprised to hear that
commentary from our committee
today anybody else representative Hill
um I'm not sure whether this was covered
in
um at any time um there was also
language in the Bill about the
requirement to have signage uh put up it
wasn't clear to me who would be
responsible for that signage and whether
that was something that would be um
required before the ticket would be
issued Andor whether that is uh the the
responsibility of the state or the
responsibility of the of um the property
owner I I don't know so that was another
question I had in my
mind represent r i i respond my
understanding would be the the uh
responsibility of the business owner the
property owner I would encourage anyone
can correct me if I'm wrong about that
but I think that that was the what I
else I was going to add a few words but
I don't think it's
necessary so the motion on the floor is
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
I'll ask the clerk to call the rooll
when she's
ready Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
de yes representative Coker yes
representative foot yes representative C
yes representative sers yes
representative Sykes no representative
Rich representative Sinclair no
representative Fox no representative r
no representative Au no representative
Jones no representative Schultz no
Representative pondon no and chairman
Walsh
nine
Hill is someone going to write the
I haven't got there yet I'm about to do
it right now
representative so our committee
recommendation of inexpedient the
legislated is adopted 10 to9 obviously
it's going on the regular calendar we'll
talk we'll talk about the majority
report is there going to be a Minority
Report okay all right so that being said
I'll close the executive session on
we're going to back up in a moment we'll
take up we do have the amendment on
House Bill
1550 so we'll take that up in a few
minutes I'll hand these out now and I
hope even though we're doing a great job
steamrolling through this that we take a
amendment I guess we got an extra
edge
be
it's
for
night
time
paragraph
d
better
all right I'm going to open up the
executive session on House Bill
1550 are we ready
are we ready about 1550 authorizing
municipalities to reduce speed limit
seasonally uh chair recognizes
representative V for a motion thank you
hp550 yes thank you Mr chairman
uh
oh okay I uh move to introduce uh
amendment
20246 51h to
hp550 can I get a second on the offering
of the
amendment seconded by representative
Jones care to speak to the
motion or no yes I get my question to
you is May May the prime sponsor speak
to the amendment is that proper procedur
or do I need to address it you should
okay my understanding is that this
inserts sub D um under the new paragraph
where it adds the language of
municipality May specify the time of day
when the reduced seasonal speed limit
effect and I believe your reading is
correct as I hold them side by side uh D
was added and it just created an e
because the current D moves down to the
next section correct any anything else
specifically on the amendment
representative SES yeah I would uh urged
the committee to support the amendment
it was one of the concerns that was
raised during the public testimony that
perhaps uh in the middle of the night
there would be not the same kind of
congestion um that was the bill was
trying to answer to and so this
Sense anybody else from the committee is
that a is that a hand up yep
representative Hill uh thank you Mr
chairman I'm trying to reconcile and it
and it may be a completely different
section but line 14 talks about the
municipality May recommend a seasonal
decrease and then how does that um
resolve itself with line 20 May specify
a time of day is that the same or is
that I don't think so and again we can
talk about it when we get to the bill
that the the the amendment is just
saying that they can the municipality
May specify the time of day of which
that reduced seasonal speed limit would
be in
effect um because if pedestrians aren't
present all day why should the um
reduction be there all day I I see it as
separate unless somebody else has got a
question
okay anybody else on the amendment
representative
pandon thank you just a probably a point
of clarification
this would affect uh or give uh
municipalities um the authority to
reduce speed limits on Class 5 highways
um the definition of a class five
Highway and I could be wrong is 30 to 35
miles an hour if I can stop you this is
to the amendment oh to the amendment we
we'll have an opportunity to speak to
the bill once once we figure out what to
do with this yeah so anything else on
the
amendment seeing
none why don't we just do a roll call on
the amendment or
instead of the hand raising that I
attempted last time heaven forbid we do
something easy like a voice
vat so the this the motion is on the
adoption of amendment
06518 and I'll ask the clerk to call the
ready
okay Vice chairman Gorski
yes representative Smith yes clerk V yes
representative Hill hi representative
T yes representative Coker yes
representative foot yes representative C
yes representative sers yes
representative Sykes yes representative
Rich yes representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Rambo yes representative auu yes
representative Jones yes representative
Schultz yes representative pund yes and
chairman Walsh
yes 19 19 to zero okay so the amendment
is adopted 19 to Zer current motion on
the floor is ought to pass as amended uh
anybody wish to speak to the bill as
amended did you still want to go thank
you Mr chair I apologize for jumping the
gun there um I just want to point a
clarification this would uh regarding
class five highways and being able to
alter them I just want to be sure to my
understanding typically they're 30 to 35
M over speed limits set by the mcds that
this state does anybody know I mean
we're not talking classifi at you know
55 M hour going down to whatever the
town
wants do we have anybody from the
Department of Transportation here that
may want to confirm that oh is that Mr
Lambert hiding in the back
see good afternoon I think now close to
it right so for the record Bill Lambert
New Hampshire dot currently the highway
safety act of Transportation
administrator but 23 years a state
traffic engineer so the answer to your
question um statutory speed limits on
All State highways it's not mutcd that's
by New Hampshire statute so RSA
26560 defined speed limits for urban
residents is 30 um and then rural
residential in class five is is
35 um so class fives outside of the
compact part of any city of town and
that's a Density definition would be
35 within the compact part of the of a
city of town would be 30 uh and this
bill address is the class five roads um
that are 35 or typically no more than
that towns can make them higher but I
don't know of any Town that's ever done
that does that get the answer you were
looking for uh thank you Mr chair just
again on the clarification is I think
the way the legislation is written is
mainly going to be those areas that are
more of an urban density which are 30 uh
the classifi as 35 I kind of don't see
that happening but we're in that realm
30 to 35 so thank you Mr chair for and
D yeah and it if you if I'm reading this
correctly it doesn't have to be 20 miles
an hour it could be increments down to
depending on the current speed limit of
the road that's that that's there so
anything else or anybody else from the
committee on
this I'll I'll go ahead representative
Smith
I just have a question uh I don't know
who can answer it so at the beginning
the amendment replaces the entire bill
right the amendment's the bill and it
begins with notwithstanding the
provisions of paragraph one RSA blah
blah or any other law to the contrary
okay then it gives the municipalities
the power to alter the speed limits and
this goes into
which is a
law and that has any alteration of speed
limits on state highways or extensions
thereof in a municipality by local
authorities shall not be effective until
such alteration has been approved by the
commissioner of
Transportation does this bill remove
Authority
yeah so to clarify the the bill creates
a process from beginning to end for how
the municipality goes about
this there's no involvement with do and
I think the disclaimer in the beginning
allows them to proceed without talking
to do about it much less having do
approve
it I'm trying to figure out if I'm
right
I think that was part of the point of
the bill that you wouldn't have to
petition the state because State already
has the authority to do this that this
would be a municipality's prerogative
commissioner this is why we need a
15minute break because I'm starting to
get a little foggy myself um fair enough
is there anybody that can offer to try
to answer this if not I'm going to take
you can try it Mr Lambert thank you
thank you
again I'll give it a try thank you Mr
chairman um this bill in the last the
last paragraph says that um design
construction installation of any
seasonal sign it shall be approved by
the commissioner of Transportation of
the Department of Transportation so that
does have to be approved by the dot uh
you could argue that the value of the
the speed limit would be part of that
signage um so I I I'd be comfortable
that we'd be involved in the process if
needed but I can tell you that in
practice um RSA 26563 that gives a lot
of communities the authority to alter
speed limits um they do not coordinate
necessarily with the dot and I had a a
selectman tell me last week that towns
can change the speed limits like that um
so as the law has applied it's not
necessarily consistent now so I think
this uh as representative V said is
intended to give the towns the same
Authority on town roads class five roads
that the state has on class two and uh
one one two and four
roads does that answer the question or
clarify it to do a degree I bet it
enough
um It also says on lines 15- 16 Upon A
basis of an Eng engineering and traffic
investigation the way this is written
that doesn't necessarily mean it'll be
you folks does
it it does not earlier in article uh in
RSA 26563 it makes reference to towns
and cities um requiring an engineering
and traffic investigation for any
alteration and it says that they uh if
they have staff that can conduct such an
investigation they do not hire to need
to hire Consultants so
paragraphs uh 1 through five of RSA
26563 cover a lot of those types of
things and right so this is what we're
going to do because I still want to look
into one other thing I said we were
going to take a break after this but
actually we're going to take a recess
right now uh for the recess that I
wanted to do anyway and to give uh a few
minutes to look into some of the
outstanding questions so with that said
I'm going to recess this executive
session
until
noon
now
he welcome back everybody we'll resume
1550 um after looking into a little bit
deeper uh I don't think I have any
any any U reservations about this it
appears that it actually is just using
26562 Roman
4 sub parag uh no Roman five paragraph
a which deals with state roads just
taking the same language over to in
putting into the alteration of limits in
26563 which is Municipal roads um I
originally well and thank you
representative Smith for looking at the
the those those terrifying words any
other law to the contrary uh I don't
think we have anything to worry about in
this particular case uh so I'm fine with
m moving on with the amendment anybody
committee okay now um with nothing else
from the committee I'll ask the clerk to
call the role wait a minute we've
already done the amendment okay so this
is ought to pass as amended
um yeah and I think we're fine at that
I'll leave it alone I'll ask the clerk
to call the role the motion is ought to
pass as
amended Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith
yes clerk votes yes representative Hill
yes representative D yes representative
Coker yes representative foot yes
representative C yes representative sers
yes representative Sykes yes
representative Rich yes representative
Sinclair yes representative Fox yes
representative Rambo yes representative
a yes representative Jones yes
representative Schultz yes
representative lundan yes and chairman
yes 19 to zero okay our committee
recommendation is adopted 19 to Z I
heard a motion for consent from
representative Jones without
objection consent it is I'll close the
1550 okay next up we'll look at House
Bill
FN
one
I'm going to open up the executive
session on House Bill would I say
1332 FN relative to prohibiting electric
vehicles from parking and parking
motion m wants representative
Jones else wants to do it I would
1332 is there a second representative
Rich care to speak to your motion
sir uh we heard from this um petitioner
um we didn't hear any testimony from any
fire department saying that there was
any data against this bill
uh I think it just takes away public
parking from the public who's entitled
to public parking so I I don't just
don't see a reason for this
bill anybody else from the
committee representative sellers thank
you Mr chair um we did actually do an
electric vehicle study not on this one
here but uh our representative Schultz
was part of it as well we actually
gathered a lot of data on it and uh
there are a lot of Hazards to have an
electric vehicle in a Gar so I'll just
state
that representative
Rumbo thank you Mr chairman uh my
understanding of the testimony at
hearing was that there are a lot of
Hazards related to weight there are a
lot of Hazards related to Old garages
there are um hazards related to tires uh
and that those are all concerns but they
are not specific to EVS there were
discussions about batteries um but there
we also got further submission um I
believe from do um sorry Dees regarding
the just lack of data of fires within
two car fires I think in New
Hampshire um there's approximately
12,000 EVS um all vehicles are heavier
now um I think there was there was a lot
of discussion that this was not an EV
problem so much as it was concerns that
arise in parking garages um and
I uh for that reason I support the itl
because I don't think this is the right
way to be addressing if we have concerns
about parking garage safety that it is
not an EV
issue representative B thank you Mr
chairman um when it comes to car
fires U we we heard testimony that the
fires are harder to put out that they
they burn hotter but as far as they're
they're also far far far less
likely our gasoline vehicles is like
four or five times more likely to catch
fire and they are just as likely to
cause
um you know excessive damage within the
garage when we look at things like the
the channel tunnel fires that shut down
the tunnels those were gas vehicles that
did that uh any any fire within an En
closed space is going to be much hotter
than a fire that's outside tires burn at
2500 degrees gasoline Burns at at 36
3700 degrees um
so they're they're not easy to put out
once they get started uh maybe you could
put it out with a with a fire
extinguisher where you know in in most
cases but in most cases by the time you
get equipment in there it's going no
matter what caused the fire it's going
to be uh out of control so um I don't
think there's any reason to Target
electric vehicles or gas powered
vehicles um we if we're looking at
weight we should look at the weight of
uh all-wheel drive vehicles versus F two
wheel drive vehicles we should look at
the weight of uh large SUVs my SEO weigh
6,500 lb versus Prius that weighs a
couple thousand at most um so as far as
weight and and and fire hazard I don't
think there's any really any difference
in the big
picture anybody else from the committee
representative Schultz I'll just say
since my name was raised by my friend um
across the way there that I agree with
this remarks of the last two speakers
and I feel like characterizing electric
vehicles in the this way is akin to
saying they're like a trabant or a Yugo
if you remember those cars and that's
just simply not the case they're
sophisticated vehicles and I feel like
um barriers to electric vehicles like
this um hurt the free market among other
things and so there's my two
cents anybody
else well I'll get some going to have to
chime in nobody else seems to want to um
I don't know if I agree with the
arguments that have been put forth this
far I have been doing a lot of research
on these vehicles um and from what I
have found and from what I have seen
actually these vehicles are heavier
they're comparable internal combustion
engine counterparts so from by one and a
half to two times as heavy and it's not
that there's an issue now when there's
only a few electric vehicles the issue
is looking at what happens when all of
the cars may be uh uh electric are the
garages even designed for it I was
surprised to find out that I was worried
more about the older garages um it's
actually the newer garages that are
built to a lesser degree of strength
than the older ones um so you can look
at weight as one thing uh maybe not an
issue now but down the road excuse the
transportation metaphor um but for me
and we have had uh meetings with fire
departments including the Fire Marshall
who are expressing a great amount of
fear over the electric vehicle fires
it's called thermal runaway now these
things can take upwards 20 25,000
gallons of water to put out it's not
like an internal combustion fire uh even
though they occur more often obviously
they do because there's a lot more of
them we're still looking at about 3% of
the vehicles being electric um but um
they can be put out with a single fire
extinguisher in a lot of cases so then
you you look at the thermal runaway
which can for prolonged periods of time
even if you can get a fire engine into
the parking garage is a problem um and
still need five tankers to put one out
uh what happens to the steel what
happens to the structure are we going to
risk the whole parking garage we've all
seen what happens when metal gets uh uh
baked if you will by intense fires so
again is this problem now with the with
the few vehicles that are out there
probably not the odds in the favor of
not an issue probably what's going to
happen the more these things become
popular so uh I'm impelled to support
the bill only because if it happens once
I think it's too many too many times and
I haven't even mentioned what happens
when you have 20,000 gallons of
contaminated water where does that go
down the onramps of a garage what
happens to the fumes that are trapped
underneath the roof from the floor above
all I can say is that if I see a Prius
going up I'm going to run for my life
and let's hope the building stands
anybody else from the
committee represent Fox thank you Mr
uh there were no instances in New
Hampshire so we're looking at a again a
exist I will say there are other states
Connecticut being one of them that have
already started doing this same thing so
it's not like we're breaking any ground
here with this Theory uh anybody else
from the committee representative a did
I see your hand go up or no okay anybody
else from the committee on this bill
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the role when she's ready the motion is
ought to uh it where am
I oh yeah inexpedient to let late on
House Bill
1332 was this motion on OTP no none of
our side wanted to give me the OTP so
they got the first stab at it in
expedient to
legislate uh Vice chairman Gorski
yes
no
okay representative Smith no clerk votes
no representative Hill no representative
Dees no representative Coker no
representative foot no representative C
no Representative sers no representative
Sykes yes representative BR yes
representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes representative
rmo yes representative U yes
representative Jones yes representative
Schulz yes representative kundan yes and
no
nine to 10 so the motion of inexpedient
to legislate fails is there another
motion representative sers thank you Mr
chair I'll make a motion not to pass
motion is not to pass is there a
second second by representative Hill any
further discussion or can we move into
the roll call Representative s thank you
Mr
chairman so I'm just going to say this
um
I believe that this is a bill that is
chasing a problem that does not exist
and I can say that with great deal of
confidence um for those of you who know
me I have 28 years of experience in the
fire
service and on top of that the last 20
of which or nearly 20 the last 17 of
which were as a fire prevention officer
whose job was to review architectural
plans fire protection plans and parking
garages are part of that that
issue all of the fears and that's just
what they are all of the fears that have
been expressed during the previous
discussion are no more than that their
fears of something that hasn't happened
yet and
yes cars do burn in garages and yes
there is runoff and yes yes there are
all the associated problems that we're
talking about but for the moment if we
were to use the logic that this is
something we need to be worried about we
would Banning we would be banning all
cars from parking garages we forget that
most parking garages constructed within
the last 30 years have an open air
requirement and most of them if not all
of them now new require a sprink system
which would help with the early stages
of new new not all of them but many of
them and I just think that this is I
think we are treading into Waters where
we where um it
is not facts but rather emotions that
are ruling our votes and I I would urge
lotp anybody else from the
committee I gu up representative
pondon I was too slow to act no wasn't
going to speak on it but way I view this
is parking garages they're either
privately owned municipally owned or
state-owned and there's different ages
and constructions and I believe it's up
to those owning entities to
regulate
limitations uh based on the structural
Eng engers of that particular structure
uh the fire apparatus of that Community
I don't think we should my view I don't
think we should blanket legislation
Statewide on parking garages when
there's entities owning entities that
really could could you know like a
hospital they could enforce Their Own no
El electric vehicles or vehicle height
they limit vehicle weight they limit so
I think we're kind of chasing something
that we don't need to at at this point
in time thank you Mr
chair anybody
else represent sellers thank you Mr
chair I'm just trying to understand the
logic here because a few bills ago we
were trying to you know keep cigarette
smoke out of cars and be preventative
and now we're trying to be preventative
here and and it's it's it's almost like
two ways and and I don't understand it
so I'm just trying to figure out what's
we're prevented one and not preventing
the other we're preventing the other and
not the other you know it's a little
confusing that's
all fair enough I don't see anything
else anybody else from the committee so
without beling it I'll um ask the clerk
to call the role the motion is uh to
pass on H Bill
1332 Vice chairman M Gorski yes yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
de yes representative Koker yes
representative foot yeses representative
C yes representative sers yes
representative
Sykes no representative Rich no
representative Clair no representative
Fox no representative Rambo no
Representative auu no representative
Jones no representative Schultz no
representative
pondon Pond
nine any objection
consent just
kidding okay our committee
recommendation
[Laughter]
is our committee recommendation about
the passes adopted 109 regular calendar
goes I'll close the executive session on
House Bill
1332 uh next we'll go into the one I
skipped inadvertently House Bill
and I'm assuming everybody would like to
March through as opposed to taking lunch
yeah
okay
okay we'll open up the executive session
on House Bill
1354 relative to special number plates
for surviving spouses of veterans J
recognizes represent flot for a
motion thank you Mr
chair I move on to pass for House Bill
1354 relative to special number plates
for surviving spouses and veterans
essentially this bill hold on hold on
okay so the motion on the floor is uh to
pass is there a second represent by
representative I mean second
representative Rumbo do you care to
speak your motion thank you yes CARiD um
so this bill looks to extend um the
opportunity for surviving spouses of
veterans to extend a license plate
indefinitely currently as it sits right
now um they have one year to surrender
those plates to the DMV um
um and we heard testimony from the state
veterans advisory committee who also
supported this and from my understanding
that's that was a a big plus to hear
from them so I would move off to pass
anybody else from the
committee nope seeing none uh the motion
on the floor is ought to pass um I'll
the clerk to call the role when she's
ready Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
de yes representative Coker yes
representative foot yes representative C
yes representative sers yes
representative Sykes yes representative
Rich yes representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Rambo yes representative Veo yes
representative Jones yes representative
Schultz yes representative kundan yes
and chairman Walsh yes 19 to
okay our committee recommendation is
adopted about to pass at 190 who motion
consent representative Jones without
objection consent it'll be I'll close
the executive
session uh next up we will get into
house bill 1329
ep one sure that's why they're there I
know
same
ready
I'll open up the executive session on
House Bill 1329 FN relative to creating
motion okay don't everybody jump all at
once I have no Vol no volunteers for
motions I'll give it one more shot
representative representative
Rich representative Rich moves out the
pass is there a second second
B I saw rbo first doesn't matter
represent seconded by representative rbo
would you can't speak to your motion
fair enough thank you anybody else from
the
committee representative Hill I'm still
puzzled I have to admit why uh a
municipal plate doesn't solve the same
the the current plate that they have
doesn't do I I don't see the point point
of a fire plate um anyone that sees a
fire truck coming down the road is going
to not look at their plate and then hold
them up because they have a municipal
plate rather than a fire plate as far as
I can see
but I don't I don't I guess I don't
much representative rbo I would add on
to that I do think there was a little
bit of confusion um potentially about
there was discussion in the hearings
about what what vehicles these would be
on but I I guess I came the conclusion
that this is just adding fire to the
vehicles that are already permitted
under statute and make it more
consistent among among the different
bodies so uh I made my peace with
it yeah from what I understand the fire
trucks right now fire vehicles municipal
fire vehicles still you run a municipal
plate it just doesn't say fire like the
police do they have their own plate and
we didn't get an answer on why they have
one and fire does not um but that's
where it's at anybody else from the
committee representative Smith actually
inquiry of the chair um are these
vehicles registered directly through the
state or through the
municipality let me look into it hold on
good
question
we have the prime sponsor here would you
like to help us with that question come
on
up I believe at this moment they go
through the municipality we go to our
us represent Smith thank you for that Mr
chair unfortunately then the fiscal note
is is way way way off um it refers to
the testing for adding the new field in
the database for the pl type with the
state systems but as longtime members of
the committee are aware the state then
is also responsible for the update to
all the municipality software there's
five different vendors and the last time
I saw a number there should actually be
around 1,600 hours of implementation and
testing not
what do they have
40 yeah
so the price tag for a new plate for
years because of the um the state's
responsibility to pay the municipalities
for the upgrade and test is typically
Grand it did you have a question
represent s Yeah question to the chair
is it possible to hear from the DMV for
cl clarification I mean the fiscal note
is what it is but if it's wrong then we
perhaps he can provide guidance here
that was my next
move you Chim in anybody from Department
Department of Motor Vehicles can you
tell us who wrote the fful
note good afternoon I'm Kathy Diamond
the supervisor at the DMV in the
registration department so just want to
clarify the first question that you had
was do Municipal agents register these
the fire tracks They don't they do the
town portion which is no fee because
it's a perm plate and they don't have
those plate types in their office so
they have to finish with us they can
renew them um no they can't even renew
them because the a perm plate so first
time issuance comes to us we renew them
all right now as well and one of the
questions that I had before was if um I
know you spoke about having it to the
volunteer people as well volunteer
firefighters but with that if they were
to get a perm plate there'd be no fees
for them so they'd have their personal
vehicle with a fire department plate on
fees
okay yeah what about the fiscal note
itself are you saying that is accurate
or inaccurate I didn't hear what the
fiscal note was it's about $25,000
28,000 and the only Department the only
Department was Department of Safety that
correct any other
questions rep representative Jones
yeah I'm hearing two different stories
uh I just heard that fire firefighters
can have it on their personal but I
didn't the bill it said was only
fire fire trucks
fire when I when I was listening to the
last um meeting that you had somebody
had brought up could they have it on
their the volunteer firefighters have it
on their personal vehicle and I heard no
okay just making sure I just want to
make sure I was no okay that that's what
I had heard to I thought Municipal
Vehicles only just for municipal
Vehicles okay so the last statement you
made about the volunteer fire
department's having plates with no fee
doesn't apply correct okay anybody else
from the committee questions for the
Department of Motor Vehicles
representative Hill um so do they um I'm
trying to resolve uh the difference
between what I heard from represent
Smith and that is there is there a cost
to creating this new
plate that uh doesn't isn't reflective
of the in the fiscal
note there would be a cost about $25,000
because we would have to certify the
vendors that we have and as well as
testing and the creation of the plate
itself so let me let me ask this
question because I agree with
representative Smith when he says that
the price or the cost for a new plate
with all the programming used to be much
much more has something changed at the
Department of Motor Vehicles uh not to
my knowledge no it hasn't and those are
numbers that I got recently
representative
Smith yeah yeah I just want to make sure
I have it right so the municipal
software does not need an update under
this bill it would need an update but
it's something that we would do and push
it out to
them follow up follow
up so you're able to push updates to the
various end software that's used they
Our IT department works with their it
department and they give them the XML to
do all of
that and they update their customers but
before they can do that we have to test
it
all and who's responsible for the
integration testing that would be
ask and you do all that for 28 grand
wow representative Hill do we know how
many we're talking
about I don't think that question was
ever asked it's a good question do you
have any idea how many Municipal Fire
Department plates there may be in the
state of New Hampshire I do
not does the prime sponsor have any
committee represent the you probably
should get uh some kind of uh
qualification how many there
are before we vote on
it I don't know that the change what
that the cost would change based on the
number of plates would it it would
not and there's always two options to
what you do when you have a bill with
this many questions the motion on the
floor is ought to pass but that's not
the only motion there so anybody
else anybody else from the
committee seeing none I'm going to ask
the clerk to call the role the motion on
the floor is thank you very much by the
1329 Vice chairman
gski
Smith
no
oh
God the clerk not sure no that's not a
I'm gonna say no for now representative
Hill no I
de representative de
no representative Coker no
representative foot no representative C
no representative sers
yes representative
sites yes representative Rich yes
representative
Sinclair yes representative Fox yes
representative Rambo yes representative
Buu yes representative Jones yes
representative Schultz yes
representative
mundon yes and chairman Walsh
no
okay
to8 the
motion right
yes okay the motion about to pass is
adopted or the recommendation is adopted
1128 obviously this is regular
calendar with that I'll close the
executive session on HB
11:23
I'm going to open up the executive
session on House Bill
registration of title exempt Vehicles
without disclosure of personal
information Beyond name and
motion representative a thank you Mr
chairman I move inexpedient to legislate
on
hb123 representative a Moves In exped to
legislate is there a
second seconded by representative Coker
care to speak to
motion yeah I think this is one we
really didn't have much testimony on the
U the prime sponsor did was not here to
introduce it and um without having more
information I would be hesitant to uh
support any other
motion anybody else from the
committee also we we had a slew of bills
that dealt with titles but the one that
we did recommend for passing Mage
actually took it away from the static
date and brought it into 20 I would
suspect that a lot of the other ones we
saw may not be needed now that we've
taken that action let's hope that one
stands or our action stands anybody else
from the committee seeing none uh I'll
ask the clerk to call the role on 11:23
the motion is in expedient to
legislate Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative
Smith yes clerk votes yes representative
Hill yes representative D yes
representative Coker yes representative
foot yes representative C yes
representative sers yes representative
Sykes yes representative Rich yes
representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes representative
rbo yes representative viu yes
representative Jones yes representative
Schultz yes representative hundon yes
and chairman W yes 19 to
zero all recommendation inexpedient to
legislate is adopted 190 motion for
consent motion by representative Rambo
without objection consent that is we'll
close the executive session one left for
folks so I I have an amendment here I'll
hand out and give you folks a few
minutes to go over
it uh again next up we'll be dealing
eight
our final executive session of the
day I'm going to open up the executive
session on House Bill
1118 relative to the issuance of
driver's licenses for aliens temporarily
residing in New Hampshire uh the chair
recognizes representative Smith for a
motion thank you Mr chair I move house
bill 1118 ought to pass motion is ought
to pass is there second representative
seconded by representative Hill uh this
bill is open to further
Amendment uh chair recognizes
representative Smith once
again thank you Mr chair I move
Amendment
06378 um Amendment 0637 H has been op
there
second representative Hill uh would you
care to speak to the part of the
amendment represent Smith thank you Mr
chair I'll speak to one portion of the
amendment um
the first part on line 13 of the
amendment the um this was actually
fixing a drafting error that I didn't
catch my apologies when it came back so
the intent here is there's no new
language added
to Roman numeral 2 what I found in the
statute was a hodgepodge if you look
down where the strikeouts are of
identifying the people the supplies to
figuring out how to determine if they
know how to drive a
car uh identification and it was all
mixed up very hard to
read the provisions that the director
may use to determine if the person knows
how to drive have all been moved to
Roman numeral
2A
previously in the statute all these
things were already listed they're in
current law right now um but the
director actually wasn't required to do
any of them which seems silly some
previous iteration of this committee
came up with all these methods and then
forgot to say oh and by the way use them
um leaving the may as it was though that
means you could do all of them so to
address the director's testimony that
some future nefarious director might
choose the one that makes it really hard
for people to get these licenses um
that's a separate issue for a separate
bill and not relevant to this that I'm
happy to talk about and file on the fall
because the reality is that same
nefarious future director could do all
of these things to somebody and make
them produce all of it uh we just want
to know they know how to drive
so I doubt that uh the director himself
or the commissioner as a supervisor
would allow this to be misused and as
far as I know it hasn't been we just
want the law to be clear that one of
these things should
occur and that is the only change to
that
section thank you Mr
chair yep thank you and I'll speak to
the rest of the amendment um it's
actually lengthy but it's it's really
not earth shattering uh it basically
just
codifies uh policies that we actually
already have and clarifies so if you see
on line 25 on the amendment uh it just
puts in rating and to make it clear that
these issue these driver's license
issued to non-resident aliens are not
considered valid identification for
identity residence or state voter
registration to follow that up uh in a
new paragraph um it simply uh requires
the director to find a place on the
license uh and be marking indicating
that the non-resident aliens driver's
license isn't for voting purposes and
this is merely to make things easier at
the polls for the
volunteers um the other thing that it
does it's again just a clarification and
um is what we've been hearing from the
department and their policies to this
point um is that uh if you see on page
two line
10 um driver licenses to an on resident
alien a a
refugee um commissioner shaugh issue a
driver's license until the refugee or S
status is complete um and that's that's
prudent to do because we don't know just
based on them coming through the Port of
Entry who these people are so this is
once you get your permanent residency
card your green card you're good to go
uh and it does look at the federal
government's issuance of temporary work
authorizations as a way around to this
and says that those uh are not U
recognized so it really isn't Earth
chattering it's just putting things into
statute that we are already
amendment well no questions I mean any
amendment
soes represent Mr chairman so um on the
amendment page two lines 10
through uh 14 is what I'm looking at um
my understanding is that the current you
you know the current practice for the
DMV is that if a person comes into the
United States applies for
Asylum and then after a period of time
the federal government government gives
that person a work permit they are then
allowed to get a driver's license and if
I read this correctly it says that they
can't do that anymore in the future and
that would
disenfranchise many many many people who
are um driving while lawfully in the
United
States Al Al director did you want to
clarify what you're doing now based on
it hold on director one second I I did I
did miss a hand of the amendment yes y
That's
what yeah that language is existing law
so I'm I'm not sure what the concerns
have to do with the amendment they are
sure we can confirm that yeah we we'll
we'll confirm that but in the meantime
the I asked the director to come up to
confirm whether or not we were issuing
driver's licenses to people with pending
cases which is what I heard we are not
thank you Mr chairman John morasco
director of the New Hampshire Division
of Motor Vehicles along with
administrator Jennifer Bailey um as
we've discussed before um until the
process is complete through USCIS um we
do not issue uh a traditional or a real
Ayes so the point that representative
SES brought up are you issuing driver's
licenses to pending asy or Refugee
status individuals that get a temporary
work authorization from the federal
government if they have an um a valid
work authorization card we do issue a
license to them because that is their
valid status at that time we're solely
talking about not issuing to those that
are in pending status of getting
anything with the United States they
don't have they just have um like a
receipt notice they've applied for their
Asylum status we would not issue them
they have to either have the work
employment card or their I94 say and
they are entered in as in
the but I thought the the the case say
Asylum for example that these were
temporary work authorizations issued by
the federal government because they have
to wait for their Asylum um hearings to
be completed which we've heard can take
a year or longer or up to 10 years so I
believe what was testified on was that
they after so many like after a year of
waiting they get granted a work
authorization card they don't get that
rate off upon entering they go through
the process if there's a weight period
and their identity is determined that
their eligible to be in us they can get
a work authorization card to work and
while their Asylum status is
granted because Asylum does grant them
different um authorities in the United
States but in in
summation when they get that temporary
work authorization their Asylum case in
most cases is still pending still
pending thank you I represent s did you
have another state another question well
yeah I want I just want to follow up if
this new section is contrary to that
practice I'm I'm trying to make it clear
in my own head whether it is or is
not I'll let Jen look at that if I may
sir could I just um Mr chairman go back
on the um the question about the status
so the save database is the federal
database that we use uh to query anybody
that comes in to make sure that um they
have that they've been vetted and they
have the status in order for us to to
issue either a traditional or um a real
ID because they've satisfied everything
through the federal government which can
take upwards and over a year in in many
cases so um but that's what we use so
the federal government has listed it as
they've completed the process and the
same database that is what we're relying
on to make that
determination and this last sentence
well the last section regardless of any
prior employment authorization would
contradict what we're doing and there
would have to be other
um law and Rule updates if we were to go
by
that fair enough anybody
else they're saying it is
contradictory and I'm saying it's
probably not a bad idea that it is
contradictory um because at some point
we still even though the federal
government decides to give an asy Seeker
uh who came
through a um Port of Entry provided a
name we don't know if it's the name the
correct name I mean there were reports
of 10 T of thousands of IDs on the other
side of the border that are being left
there uh so we still don't know who
these people are in spite of the fact
that they've gotten this work
authorization so that's a way in my
opinion of the federal government to do
a a way around of this and this this
would stop that well if if I could sir
the um so Jonathan Mills from USCIS who
I had spoken with um I don't know
probably a year and a half ago now I've
testified before this committee um
during the last session about my
conversation with him and I really tried
to drill down on exactly what the
process consists of I used several
different examples um what he explained
to me was um if you had a situation
where somebody um came into the United
States and they did not necessarily go
through the proper channels to do that
and they went to a US CIS
office and they applied for uh Asylum
status that the first part of that
process through USCIS is to confirm
identity and that he said when the
receipt is issued that starts the clock
ticking to work towards identity and the
first phase of that process if you will
is that they're able to do that if
they're able to do that they confirm the
identity but for the State of New
Hampshire just that confirmation from
USCIS that identity has been established
that still doesn't change what we do
here which is what we're talking about
fulfillment of the entire process um to
include in some cases an interview but
not in every case um as I'm told and uh
as well as a background investigation
what the merits of that are I don't know
I I would leave that to somebody else
but they do establish Identity or or try
to um at that first phase and when they
do that does go into um that is
marked the um one additional thing the
work employment card isn't flagged as to
who that's issued to so work employment
cards are also issued as a general
status as well as to those that have
been here on student visas then
transition to a work employment card so
when we're being handed a work
employment card we don't know whether
they're being they're under a pending
Asylum or not they could be here as a
previous um student visa or just here in
General on a work employment card we
would have no way to determine if that
person was pending an asylum status we
would have to stop issuing to anyone
card I'll have to look at that again I
don't think so because it says
notwithstanding I say 263 39a but thank
you for the information anybody else
from the committee questions of the
director seeing none thank you very much
thank you Mr uh any other comments
thoughts on the amendment repr you one
of the things that we thank you Mr
chairman one of the things we've always
opposed uh because um aliens that are
that are here legally that have
fulfilled all the process and gotten a
driver's license um a fully valid
driver's license
um we don't we we tend to oppose the
designation that they non-resident alien
on the license because they become
targets um they even without that alien
uh Alien residents become have been
targeted for violence discrimination by
putting that on the card and they they
have to go and buy cigarettes they have
to go in buy alcohol present it at a at
a bar it opens them up up to uh
potential discrimination and violence so
I would oppose it just based on that
part of the
amendment thank you and in response I
thought about that as well that's why I
left it up to the director to finds a
suitable marking uh we've had bills in
the past that required citizenship or
other other things and that was the
argument back then but this just leaves
it up to coming up with something subtle
and something that is just
identifiable uh anybody else from the
committee seeing none this is on the
amendment
06378 I'll Grant the ranking member one
more thank you I I I just want to follow
up on your your comment which was
accurate and I just want to reemphasize
it we have had in my time in the legisl
of multiple
bills come before the Full House to be
voted on that would require some type of
marking that would make a different
class of driver's license and they have
been roundly defeated on a strongly
bipartisan fashion I he I hesitate and
worry that we are now doing something
that would contradict the history of
this uh of the house thank you
any other well I gave a ranking member
one last chance I was in the motion in
in the process of uh calling the
question on the adoption of amendment
0637 H I'll ask the clerk to call the
ready Vice chairman Gori
yes representative Smith yes CL votes
yes representative Hill yes
representative de yes representative
Coker yes representative put yes
representative
C yes representative sers yes
representative Sykes no representative
Rich no representative Sinclair no
representative Fox no representative
Rambo no representative Vio no
representative Jones no representative
Schultz no Representative hondon no and
chairman Walsh yes
10 to
the vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes CL votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
de yes representative Coker yes
representative foot yes representative C
yes representative sers yes
representative
Sykes no representative Rich no
representative Sinclair no
representative Fox no representative
Rambo no representative ve no
representative Jones no representative
Schultz no Representative panden no and
nine
M um Mr chairman is your plan uh on the
lemonade boat idea uh how are you how
through
my question um was whether there was the
last conversation I'm aware of there was
um some question whether what the Marine
Patrol stopped the young boy
for was was not in statute there was
nothing that affected it I was wondering
if the chair intends to talk to I saw
Tim duny here today and I wondered
whether that
conversation um needed to go through him
or someone else in order to find out
whether there actually is a restriction
on what the kit does on the
lake in the work that I do this week dun
Le Mr Captain dun Levy retired will
certainly be part of the
conversation I will also request that
he's here next Tuesday when we have our
work session uh with our our executive
session later in the day thank
you anything else from the
committee again thank you very much
anybody and yes please committee reports
I am going to sneak out to get something
to eat but I'll be hanging around please
give me your reports before you before
you peel out of here I do do we have any
more copies hard copies I have some
right here if you'd like to do it on
paper as opposed to electronically so
again